your opponent is lining up a putt to win
the match you get to whisper one thing
in their ear to break his concentration
what do you say it's simple i'd just be
walking on
the car path with some spikes
your cleats do the talking the spikes
drowned out the sound of his mouth so i
don't mind he's like that's actually
they're fine
why was their tension before was that
like hey i want to be the buffest guy in
tour no i want to be the buffett's guy
where did that even start just
there's not much in common like just
just be flat out honest there's not much
in common there's a lot in common just
two shocked just two alphas
that just don't get along yeah exactly
why did they choose 12 holes is because
it's just you guys would be too
exhausted or what's the reason for that
they wanted to give bryson a chance to
beat his back nine score at the u.s open
say something nice about the other
person
uh he's got great teeth oh there we go i
agree i saw him look at this look at his
face right now he's like this is a hard
one very hard i'm still trying to figure
it out
[Laughter]
come on you got to say something i am
speechless uh maybe talk about it the
first time okay with a microphone in
front of my face i am speechless wow
i don't think we've ever gotten along
liked each other whatever welcome back
to the match bryson
thanks guys glad to be back it's gonna
be a lot of fun today and we're going to
see
who gets it done today for sure first
off though i know it was thanksgiving
yesterday
but i wanted to show off a little
support in thanksgiving and this new
friendsgiving so i got some brooks kefka
cupcakes for everyone in the crowd
and if brooks wants the last one he can
have it but anyone wants to have it you
guys pass it around take one come on my
man
you know just a little something for you
guys but i wanted to start it off good
and clean
so anybody that wants the right there
there you go there you go all right
anyway good luck today man let's have
some fun all right
all right cupcake olive branch filled
this is cute all right there's to go
three up
[Music]
any questions
man i haven't seen a beat down like this
as me and phil put it on pain and stuff
i get pop cash thank you
all right
it's a runaway train
he did say it wasn't going to go 12.
he did say that
so how are you feeling about your
prediction right now
there you go
there you go
there you go bro and it was more than
just a prediction
oh yeah no he said it multiple times
don't worry
there's there is respect there but at
the same time it was fun to come out
here and settle this and um
enough said wait did we just become best
friends for the next one va